what do you think
is going through
mr putin's mind this morning
well that's obviously the key question
that we're all trying to work out and i
think what we have to appreciate is the
extent to which putin is not the kind of
person who
fixes himself in a particular
track and timetable and rigorously
sticks to that he clearly believes in
creating options for himself and then
constantly reassessing them so i mean
what he will be doing today is we're
told that there is this war plan
that would actually be triggered on
wednesday
maybe maybe not but on the other hand
you know he'll be looking at well what
are the likely costs of actions what are
the likely benefits so this is it i mean
i think he will constantly be
reassessing that and i think that is why
it's so important that we keep up both
the the pressure
but also make it clear that there are
off ramps because unfortunately if we
give him an option which is essentially
between escalation and capitulation then
he will probably escalate
what um what does an off-ramp look like
in this context that's a very
interesting concept
well what we have to realize is that
first of all russia believes that it has
some genuine security concerns now we
may disagree with a lot of the basic
precepts about whether nato is
aggressive and so forth but just simply
telling the russians that they're wrong
is not going to get them to say oh my
apologies we'll back away so they have
to have
an opportunity to basically talk through
their various issues
secondly there are a lot of specific
issues many which frankly the americans
have already brought on to the table
that in some ways what we have to do is
talk them up as concessions to the
russians it may well and it does stick
in the craw to in effect act as
president putin's pr agents but in some
ways we we must get away from a
situation in which we're trying to push
him into a position where he will feel
that he's been defeated and instead we
want him to feel that what we're
offering which does not in any way
infringe on ukrainian sovereignty and
the wider european security architecture
but what is already there actually is a
genuine step forward for him so a lot of
this is frankly smoke and mirrors which
is after all what diplomacy is often all
about
well it's very interesting insight into
mr putin's psychology i talked to
mikhail kordekovsky the
russian billionaire and former friend i
suppose uh or associated of mr putin and
he
said that he was a little bit paranoid
and
um
putin once said i haven't got quote in
front of me but i think putin once said
that the um the russian bear could be
quiet but on the other hand
uh if it's
stayed quiet then its enemies would be
uh tearing its claws and fangs out and
that therefore
i suppose in a way they had to be
aggressive
what do you think about that assessment
putin basically
uh is not just smart but also paranoid
i think there is a lot of paranoia in
not just putin but a lot of people
around him remember these people in
their late 60s and early 70s a lot of
them veterans of the kgb all of them
though products of the old circuit
system so they still have a lot of the
old attitudes and they're also the ones
who are probably most caught by the
traumatic end of empire which is
metastasized from uh what have we lost
to uh and who took it from us so yes
there there is a very toxic
perspective on the west there but go
back to the point about the
the russian bear is look
unfortunately the russians have
internalized rightfully a sense that the
west only pays attention to russia when
russia causes problems for the west
and there's a certain amount of truth in
that and unfortunately that means
obviously without any way excusing what
putin is doing we shouldn't be surprised
that the russians continue to make
problems for us because that's how they
they get our attention but i think that
is the key thing if all he wanted to do
was crack the whip on ukraine he could
have done it by now he could have done
it much more quickly and with with much
less of this kind of lengthy almost
theatrical buildup the fact that we have
this is a sign that at least putin is
hoping that he can get something through
negotiation rather than having to
unleash the troops with all the massive
political economic and social costs that
would involve
so that really leads us to the key
question
how likely do you think an invasion is
it sounds as though you think
not very likely
i mean that that is the question and
unfortunately then no doubt i will be
proven wrong whatever i i predict and i
think this is the thing at the moment
it's only putin who gets to decide and
we don't know what he's thinking for
certain my view is that invasion or some
substantial military escalation is not
his plan a
he's absolutely hoping to use all these
other methods intimidation diplomacy
covert attacks and so forth to get
enough of concessions that he feels he's
actually managed to make his point and
put russia at the center of the world
again which is where he thinks it should
be
that doesn't mean though that military
escalation is not there as a plan b or a
plan c as an option if he really feels
that he's not going to get anything
anywhere then anyway he will probably
feel he has little option but to
escalate to a degree maybe not these
kind of apocalyptic scenarios we've been
hearing about rolling the tanks around
kiev and so forth but some kind of
military escalation just to make a point
but as i said i think that that's still
plan b
if i was going to guess i think there's
going to be a war on wednesday
i will say not
sorry um
last question i guess um
in this rather delicate
balance of decision making
how
helpful is the
defense secretary's reference to munich
and essentially appeasement
i mean it's unfortunate not least
because it obviously cursed the russians
as nazi germany which you know for a
country which lost so much in the second
world war which still calls it the great
patriotic war that's a very neuralgic
point but i mean i think in in fairness
the russians are sophisticated enough to
realize that there is the the dialogue
that you have with your own domestic
audience and the dialogue you have with
other countries and in fact ben
wallace's visit to moscow seems to have
actually been pretty successful it was
very sober it wasn't a
highly publicized spat it was actually
two people trying to talk about
challenges and also the the parallel and
very important talks between chief of
the defense staff admiral radekin and
his russian counterpart general
gerasimov so i mean actually in no sense
i think ben wallace has probably
accumulated enough credit that he can be
allowed a few rhetorical flourishes as
far as moscow is concerned